Tom DeLay is signing books at the trover
bookshop here on Capitol Hill its
authors night it's sponsored by the hill
newspaper mr. delay you signed that book
for that gentleman keep the faith why'd
you sign it like that well the book is
about challenging people to know what
you believe in and fight for what you
believe in it's it uses me in my life as
an example and so my motto over my
entire political career has been keep
the faith whatever it means to you keep
the faith in your government keep the
faith in your your country keep the
faith in yourself just keep the faith
and fight for it title of the book is no
retreat no surrender why is that well I
want to want to send the message to
people that I had was not retreating by
stepping down from Congress that in fact
I am more busy than ever before in in
pushing the conservative movement and
supporting Israel so I'm very much
involved in that I haven't given up one
day and I'm still fighting for what I
believe in what's life like outside of
the Dome of the Capitol it's wonderful
you get to be with your family you
actually have weekends off you actually
get off by six o'clock and go to dinner
with friends I mean it's it is wonderful
and you get to you get to do and say
what you ever you want to without fear
of reprisal and and it's such a freeing
experience to step out of Congress and
move forward I'm very proud of our
record I'm very proud of my service but
at the same time I'm looking forward to
a new future do you think the
Republicans in part were guilty of
overspending and thus responsible for
their own fate and six now I think that
was it was part of it the perception of
overspending but if you look at the
record we did an incredible job
especially compared to the Democrats in
Congress now I mean they're spending
with abandoned they're raising taxes
we we held the line it was 12 years of
no tax increases in the federal
government and if you look at
particularly in the bush years
non-defense discretionary spending was
held below inflation and in 2002 was
actually cut for the first time since
Ronald Reagan and the percent of overall
federal spending has never gotten back
to what the Democrats been in the early
90s so it's unfortunate that people have
that perception and it's our fault that
they have that perception but it was a
combination of a lot of things not the
least of which the Democrats over the
last six years have been built one of
the most powerful impressive coalition's
political coalition's that I've ever
witnessed and they used it Republicans
Republicans have nothing like it do you
ever talk to newt gingrich uh yeah
occasionally we're not buds but yeah we
have the great at most respect for each
other I don't know of a smarter man and
then Newt Gingrich and his
advice is always welcome who do you like
in a way I don't have a candidate now my
heart's favorite is mike huckabee I've
known Mike Huckabee for 25 years he is
what you see he doesn't have to design
what he believes in and he's standing up
for a good conservative cause former
Majority Leader Tom DeLay here's his
book no retreat no surrender on one
Americans fight co-authored are helped
with by Steven Mansfield who's he Steve
a man's does a dear friend of mine a
prolific author himself he wrote the
faith of George W and has written many
other books and over the years I've come
to know him and he's the one that forced
me to write the book well you're here at
the trover bookshop and you're seated
next to Christopher Hitchens ought
accident actually I have the utmost
respect for Christopher is it why is
that because he's a man that knows what
he believes in it stands up and fights
for what he believes you're known as a
born-again Christian christopher
hitchens is not what do you think about
that issue well I don't agree with his
approach but because faith I think is is
everything and truth comes from from God
and so I don't agree with that I don't
agree with some of what he does I have
great admiration for other things like
his support for the war in Iraq and and
all of that and and his ability to tell
them what he thinks it's the truth it's
pretty impressive well Christopher
Hitchens book Christopher Hitchens book
god is not great has been nominated for
a 2007 National Book Award mr. Hitchens
what do you think about that I think
there are too many prizes in this
business do you want to win and if I
wanted to if you go to you're willing to
go to events were writers give each
other awards you need never dine alone
you could be out every night of the week
so will you this is a this is a serious
award I mean I my publisher says big
deal will you be at the dinner on
November 14th in New York
I think it would be churlish not to go
to the gym since they've been so nice as
to and apparently there's money if you
win it's not just a statuary what I had
to give it back it goes to my editor so
the fingers on his desk and there's no
money in it so what the hell is this let
me go to imagine you're still spending
quite a bit of time God the Pulitzer I
wrote him a letter saying I think no
less of you I think that's the way to do
it so you've been spending quite a bit
of time debating Christians around the
country sue yes and well I caught myself
making an idiotic Vermont the other day
at the end of one of these debates which
was with a senior theologian Alister
McGrath at Georgetown last week as it
was over I said to myself they never
come up with any new arguments and I
thought to myself well they wouldn't
with that these are old arguments it's
no disgrace that they're old it's that
we have better explanations now where
we're from why we're here who we are
where our cosmos comes from well
religion was the first and the worst but
at least it was first to try philosophy
and biology as a former Majority Leader
Tom DeLay been lobbying you at all on
the issue of religion no we've disagreed
to be children sho shoulder to shoulder
against the theocratic terrorists in
Iraq on that we are faith-based scumbags
will not take over mess paternity him
Christopher Hitchens and i haven't had a
bad day